y él quisiera en primer lugar que nos
cuenten qué está ocurriendo
concretamente con los familiares de
críticos al gobierno de ortega y cómo
proceden en esa toma de rehenes
aunque
escuché te decía que lo primero que hay
que comprender la situación nicaragüense
es que en nicaragua no existe estado de
derecho ni existe digamos un poder
judicial que se salvaguarde los derechos
de la población todo lo contrario hay
toda un entramado que persigue a
opositores activistas a defensores de
derechos humanos que es lo que está
pasando en este momento en este momento
el régimen ha intensificado su
estrategia represiva y está deteniendo a
familiares de opositores activistas y
diferentes voces disidentes nosotros
como colectivo pudimos recibir
recientemente el 15 de septiembre la
denuncia de uno de ellos que pudo huir
del país pero su familia en este momento
dos ciudadanas francesas
la señora jianing jorbi liu cuadra ana
carolina álvarez orbi liu y su yerno
félix roy se encuentran en este momento
privados de su libertad en la dirección
de auxilio judicial y cuéntenos qué tipo
de acciones cree que serían necesarias
para contrarrestar el accionar del
gobierno de ortega y en este sentido de
más qué rol tiene la comunidad
internacional no
bueno santiago esta es una situación sin
precedentes en la historia nicaragüense
es decir ni la dictadura de somoza que
fue una dictadura brutal se atrevió a
meterse con las familias es decir
detenerlo y llevarlo al centro de
detención conocido como el chipote
solamente un poco para recordar el
chipote es un centro de tortura es decir
es un centro incluso donde han pasado
personas detenidas por meses sin que
sean presentadas las personas que te
mencionaba tanto tanto anna carolina
como janine como félix estas personas no
han sido presentadas a ninguna autoridad
están en una condición de desaparición
temporal
forzada que es gravísimo lo que le toca
a la comunidad internacional es no
mantenerse indiferente ante lo que está
pasando en nicaragua
yo quiero recalcar que lo que pasa en
nicaragua es una de las situaciones más
graves de américa latina' y posiblemente
del mundo en cuanto a violación de
derechos humanos y activar todos los
mecanismos posibles que da el derecho
internacional para poder enfrentar para
poder no solamente denunciar sino
también obligar a ortega a que libera a
los presos políticos que en este momento
son más de 200 precisamente a recién
adelantada un poco de lo que le voy a
preguntar ahora más concretamente no
cuál es la situación en los centros de
detención en materia de derechos humanos
bueno hace dos semanas luego de más de
un año de estar presionando para que
presentaran a los presos políticos
el régimen accedió y ha presentado a más
de una veintena de ellos y lo que
pudimos ver en las pocas imágenes y en
la fotografía es que muchísimos de ellos
han adelgazado de 30 a 50 libras y lo
que nosotros como organismo de derecho
humano hemos podido constatar a través
de la familia es que hay en esos centros
de detención específicamente en el
chipote hay una política de destrucción
físicas y emocional de los presos y
presas políticas es decir se cometen
claros de tortura y de tratos crueles
inhumanos y degradantes es una situación
gravísima